a
[Música]
y dice ah bien visto en una ciudad
portuaria de inglaterra el juicio contra
cuatro personas por el desmonte en junio
de 2020 de la estatua del traficante de
esclavos
edward colston en medio de este
movimiento originado en los eeuu black
life mata y que ha tenido un impacto
enorme aquí en el reino unido en donde
70 memorias han sido removidos o
renombrados por sus lazos con la
esclavitud con el racismo y con el
tráfico de esclavos y también con el
colonialismo según una investigación del
periódico the gardian en donde se han
desmontado 30 estatuas pero además se
han cambiado en nombres de universidades
de escuelas de edificios de pubs y de
iglesias los expertos han calificado
como histórico este intento del reino
unido por modificar esta parte de su
historia
[Música]
en california en la ciudad de san
francisco ha votado este mes para
cambiar el nombre a 44 escuelas que
estarían cuyos nombres estarían ligados
a figuras con un pasado racista o
ligados a la esclavitud como por ejemplo
figuras icónicas aquí en eeuu como
george washington o abraham lincoln pero
también incluso figuras políticas mucho
más recientes como la senadora diane
feinstein a quien acusan de no haber
cambiado con la suficiente rapidez una
bandera confederada del ayuntamiento de
san francisco hace varias décadas entre
las voces críticas contra esta nueva
medida se encuentran también bueno
varias organizaciones hispanas porque
entre los nombres que se quieren cambiar
está también el de junípero serra una
figura muy controvertida ligada a las
misiones aquí en california
sus detractores le acusan de haber
convertido a la fuerza a los nativos al
catolicismo y también bueno pues haber
esclavizado y haber causado el
sufrimiento de muchas personas aquí en
california
[Música]
mientras que en diferentes partes del
mundo se están tratando de eliminar las
estatuas y antiguos símbolos coloniales
de las épocas del imperialismo en
sudáfrica este es un movimiento que ya
lleva varios años y es una iniciativa
tanto ciudadana como institucional
después de que cayó la parte aído unos
pocos años más tarde en los años 2000 el
gobierno empezó a renombrar algunas de
las ciudades principales eliminando sus
nombres coloniales por ejemplo pretoria
se llama también swan durban & queens y
port elisabeth se llama nelson mandela
bay
el tema de los monumentos también está
en el centro del debate eliminar
monumentos como el de la estatua de
cecil rhodes originó el movimiento rose
más folk en la universidad de ciudad del
cabo en 2015 se trataba de quitar la
estatua de este antiguo colonizador
cecil road que oprimió tanto a los
pueblos locales este movimiento daría
origen a fish más folk o las matrículas
deben caer otro movimiento estudiantil
que más adelante se convertiría en un
movimiento a escala nacional por los
derechos humanos y por la igualdad para
todos los sudafricanos esto a través de
resignificar los antiguos símbolos
coloniales con una historia
descolonizada y con referentes locales
[Música]